pablo rotelli merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors au chili 23
milliards demandés au fmi le ministre
des finances a précisé que cette ligne
de crédit ne serait pas alloué à la
dépense publique et aux aides sociales
en pleine crise de coronavirus on aurait
pu s'attendre à des fonds destinés à
l'urgence de la situation
est ce que cette déclaration du surprend
alors non parce qu'on l'a été le femi
n'est pas là pour pour soutenir la mal
nommée dépenses publiques
ils ont été recouvrés aussi les
investissements publics alors notons
aussi que le déficit public est un
excédent du secteur privé donc il faut
se serait tu rêves est de réduire le
déficit drastiquement en tout cas ce que
fait le chien en appelons au fmi c'est
essayer de calmer des créanciers le femi
agit comme une sorte de label de qualité
qui garantit que le pays va payer ses
créanciers et ses 23 milliards de
dollars qui est la moitié du prêt
standby contractée par l'argentine ya
quelques années c'est pas de temps que
sa réalité par la dette totale du chili
mais ils sont là pour assurer le
paiement des prochaines séances des
prochaines échéances qui vont tomber
cette année leur prochaine donc c'était
du fmi finalement n'est pas là non plus
pour pour venir pour régler une partie
de la crise
socio économique non non pas du tout la
seule chose que fait le chili s'est
acheté du temps comme ça c'est une
manière de refinancer la dette avec le
dernier prêteurs possible lorsque vous
faites appel au fmi c'est que vous ne
pouvez plus rouler votre dette
il faut nécessairement un dernier
organisme qui arrive qui dit bon écoute
et maintenant vous allez vous allez
accepter les conditions on allait
restructurer l'économie comme comme on
vous le demande
et en échange ça en vous on vous prête
les liquidités dont vous avez besoin à
court terme pour faire face aux
échéances l'ictu les plus proches alors
là ne résout absolument pas le problème
de la dette au chili alors la situation
est également catastrophiques dans
d'autres pays du monde
au liban notamment qui a commencé hier
sa négociation est au liban est ce qu'on
peut comparer la situation à celle du
chili alors j'irai au delà même du liban
il ya il ya par exemple à l'article de
médiapart qui montre qu' il faudrait une
amie nations 2000 milliards de dollars
de dette pour éviter une cascade de
défaut de paiement alors et là vous
voyez que au niveau mondial
un rapport de force s'installe entre les
créanciers et les débiteurs parce que
pour un pays faire défaut ça veut dire
quoi c'est pas juste que le pays arrête
de payer sa dette c'est à dire qu'il ne
peut plus endettés en devises
et si les pays d'un peu plus endettés en
devises par exemple l'argentine ne
pouvait plus accéder au dollar si n'est
plus acceptée au dollar un peu importe
et elle ne veut plus perdre sa cape et
sa capacité à porter la capacité à
octroyer des crédits en dollars aussie
est fortement limité donc le coût du
crédit augmente et on a un risque
systémique énorme 26 si vous multipliez
ce risque systémique par la totalité des
pays dans le monde qui sont qui sont à
deux doigts du défaut de paiement
là vous avez l'autre si vous voulez une
autre étape du rapport de force que
c'est facile serait favorable à ces pays
dans le sens où s'il ya un défaut
généralisé est bien là les créanciers
ont peur très concrètement parce que ce
sont très souvent des fonds
d'investissement si lors si leurs actifs
si leurs actifs se déprécie ont bien
lorsque lorsque ces fonds
d'investissement rôle leur dette est
bien avec les prêteurs de ces fonds
d'investissement pourraient
considéré qu' ils vont cesser d'être
solvable sous peu par conséquent ils
cessent de rang les leurs dettes donc
refinancer la dette de ces fonds et par
conséquent ses fons finalement passerait
d'une crise de liquidité à une crise de
solvabilité ce serait un embrasement
généralisé de la finance mondiale mais
relativisons quand même ces chiffres
parce que c'est 1000 milliards dont je
vous parle c'est rien par rapport à la
dette mondiale à la dette mondiale
atteinte cent cinquante mille milliards
de dollars ce qui représente 3 120 % du
pib mondial
et si on compare aux marchés
obligataires sait rien non plus parce
que le lait totalité de la bulle
obligataire mondial atteint 115 mille
milliards de dollars
alors vous me direz comment c'est
possible que la chose n'est pas encore
explosé parce que simplement grâce à
l'intervention des banques centrales qui
rachète de manière pratiquement illimité
à des actifs publics et privés sur le
marché secondaire aux états unis en
europe et au japon et royaume uni
donc alors plus plus de 300
parlementaires d'une vingtaine de pays
ont appelé c'était mercredi le fmi et la
banque mondiale a annulé justement la
dette des pays pauvres face aux
conséquences économiques potentielles
delà de la pandémie due nouveau
coronavirus est ce que c'est une
solution pour un nouveau départ alors
c'est un début de solution mais tant que
les causes structurelles de
l'endettement reste intacte ça ne fait
que gagner de danse à ça si vous voulez
ça ça laisse respirer ces pays
mais en réalité ce sont des dettes
envers le fmi et la banque mondiale le
fmi la banque mondiale ne peux pas
parler au nom du reste des créanciers
qui devrait accepter des
restructurations par exemple alors
justement pour conclure en quelques mots
comment ces pays émergents peuvent-ils
ou doivent-ils se réinventer et bien il
y as en 1983 lorsque la dictature
argentine prend fin par exemple le
nouveau gouvernement radical paul
alfonsi nomme un tant que ministre
d'économie barbara bach greenspan qui
avait une idée très bonne en réalité qui
était de créer un club de débiteurs
latine américain afin que les pays
endettés puisse négocier d'égal à égal
avec les créanciers qui eux sont bloc
il ne se laisse pas diviser les
créanciers des pays auraient intérêt à
diviser les créanciers pour négocier des
accords favorable que l'un est ensuite
utilisé cet accord favorable pour forcer
la négociation chez les autres il ne se
laisse pas faire pour pourquoi les pays
soeur et bien sominice d'économies a été
a été ensuite viré parce que son idée a
été a été refusée par le fmi et par les
états unis qui évidemment sont gagnants
dans la sphère de la dette des pays
latino-américains mère ça serait une
piste de solution
merci beaucoup pablo ortelli le d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes enseignant en économie et
spécialiste de l'amérique latine